[Music]
this is a daily pastime for these
youngsters herding cattle on the Shere
Khan boy as they call it here they've
grown up with the animals cattle
breeding is king here in this region
alta floresta a municipality in the
north of the brazilian state of mato
grosso is located in the Amazon biome
and it's cowboy country many locals say
that 30 years ago there was nothing here
by nothing they mean rain forests since
then they've opened the land for
development and they're proud of that
they came here with the government's
encouragement they were encouraged to
DeForest encouraged to cultivate the
land then new laws were passed and they
were told they couldn't clear the forest
anymore first they're supposed to cut
down the trees now they're supposed to
reforest some areas that change of
course is led to conflict this conflict
is a reality across much of the region
the soil on many farms is no longer
productive enough to support cattle one
cow requires a hectare of land that's
land that doesn't go toward feeding
people and the environmental cost is
high with the forests gone the cattle
roam freely destroying the remaining
vegetation and polluting the springs
Houston was almost it was so the
situation here is completely backward
this area should never have come under
cultivation it's under permanent nature
conservation there shouldn't be any
cattle here and it should never have
been deforested this is how it looks on
most farms in the area because this is
how the animals get access to water
that's why we want to bring the water to
the cattle rather than the cattle to the
water in entres is animosity agua
Livan Michael's company paksa aims to
transform cattle ranching here in
compliance with environmental laws he
and his partners came up with the idea
and it's urgently needed it all started
three years ago on this ranch the soil
has been replenished and there's a new
production model it involves fenced in
paddocks rotational grazing and most
importantly a new source of water and a
special cattle feed owners also
Bevilaqua put his faith in the coal the
environmental conservationists as many
here view him the experiment paid off
now the ranch consisting three thousand
five hundred head of cattle a larger
herd or much less land and they're ready
for slaughter after just two years this
is how the cattle management works when
the grass has reached a height of about
one meter or eighty centimeters we let
the cattle into the paddock they eat the
best part of the cross the leafy part at
the top after two or three days we close
that paddock and open the gate to the
next one where the grass has reached the
optimal height I mean this hem is
motoring in the meantime the other
pasture areas can recover this system is
easier on the soil the farmers also grow
a different type of grass than is usual
for the region mombasa grass is rich in
protein but requires the grazing cattle
to be rotated regularly it's changed a
lot the entire area you see here was
totally degraded for 25 years all we did
was exploit the land until it could
hardly produce anything anymore through
the partnership with pexif we've turned
it into a flourishing garden for the
cattle and productivity has increased a
lot it's practically quadrupled the qtm
which applicable quite
the land around the springs and on the
river margins has been reforested in
some cases even more than the law
demands according to McCall water for
the cattle is now piped to the pastures
from the basin improved water quality
also helps increase yield the
rehabilitated soil can take up more co2
and the modified fodder means the cattle
produce less methane paksas business
model aims to reap both environmental
protection and profits the company helps
increase yields and in return receives a
large share of the surplus for six years
soil remediation is expensive it
requires several passes with heavy
machinery and large quantities of
nutrients the added lime alone amounts
to one term per hectare in the song
ranges the ranches are big we're not
talking about farms of 10 or 20 hectares
we're talking about ranches of 700
hectares and more that quickly brings
costs to about a million and a half
reais more than 300 thousand euros
that's a sum that most ranchers can't
come up with on their own what happens
then
ranchers who can't afford to invest such
large sums risk going under and that
makes them easy prey for the soybean
Lobby it's an increasing presence in the
region and benefits from the current
political climate in the country the
focus of this event bringing together
producers and politicians is expanding
the agricultural front in his speech the
district chairman says the region takes
great pride in its potential for growth
he says alta floresta was once a city of
gold prospectors and loggers now it's
become a center of cattle ranching and
finally agribusiness is moving in too he
says
the widespread view here still is that
only deforested land is productive land
forests cost tax money and don't bring
in big yields the packs are founders
take a pragmatic approach they don't
expect reforestation to happen on a
grand scale here but it can succeed on a
small scale and chip away at entrenched
beliefs our main argument in favor of
reforestation is the protection of water
sources what use is a cattle ranch if
you have no water on your land that's a
strong argument to win them over the
idea is that it's better to preserve the
region's cattle ranches if they shut
down new ranches will crop up elsewhere
and that will bring more deforestation
livestock farming doesn't look set to
disappear any time soon many forecasts
indicate that global beef consumption
will continue to rise for decades to
come
that production has to come from
somewhere all the studies suggests that
the place with the greatest potential
for meeting this demand is Brazil and
the Amazon region so we have a choice
where do we produce we say it should be
done on land that's already been
deforested and on those areas we can
increase productivity by a factor of two
three seven or even ten in the Amazon
alone there are an estimated 12 million
hectares of degraded pasture land that
offers lots of potential for sustainable
and profitable Land Management
you